hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
and I'm John so today we are gonna watch
something that was requested see because
one of our special patreon reward tiers
which by the way we have over 250 video
posts on there right now we started
doing TV show reactions gonna be filming
more throughout the week and we do a lot
of music video reactions over there John
especially is doing a lot of music video
reactions because most of the time
anything music gets blocked on YouTube
yeah
little pets unplug we do Q&A stuff that
we teach one throw that out there but
one of the big reward tiers is whatever
you request we must definitely do a
reaction to you have to or commentary on
and do it on youtube so this one today
is coming from a lovely lady named spree
spree has requested that we watch this
video the greatest showmen this is me
with Kayla Seto it's behind in his new
song oh this is me and we knew that it
was going to be the anthem of the film
but no one had heard of before thank you
as my favorite self and who I didn't
even want to come out from behind the
music state I didn't I kept saying then
just step out because this is your
moment and you have to step out into the
ring metaphorically because that's what
you're doing here to stand right there
in front of everyone
I just belted behind that so the day of
that presentation there was a moment in
the song that actually was so scared
that I had to actually grab his hands so
that I had something to hold on to and
then we got to the end of the number and
all I remember is just deafening
deafening will save me the rest of my
life
[Music]
Wow it's basically respective move me
along
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
it's some ways that's more powerful than
the movie itself well yeah it just feels
really natural the way that whole thing
built up and just like the more the song
goes on the more the magic in the rooms
are the sorts elevating up and
everyone's just feeling it and moving
you know you even see the people at the
table at first just like yeah right now
they're all standing there all singing
along oh yeah feel it seems like they're
really feeling like a cast yeah almost
flashed me back just to do it you know
doing the play back in the day or
whatever this makes you appreciate the
film a lot more and that's crazy then
this is the moment that got the movie
greenlit was this video right here I
mean like [ __ ] tearing up yeah it's a
green that's a movie especially that
passion and and pressure that I'm like
kiella settle I had to you know because
you could tell she's nervous but she
just has to give it her all right now
and just really feel it I love that
moment where she's just seen up there
and then she breaks away from the mic
and just starts going to the yeah going
in the room and then before you know it
has the whole room moved and you're like
yeah that's in admit man when I saw this
movie don't I recommended this movie and
yeah and when I saw it when she sings
that number specifically after a very
pivotal moment for the groups of the
freaks to get to have a pretty
disparaging moment and then they start
singing it that was really an inspiring
moment for me and it did bring me to
tears when I watched it but this was a
whole different kind of experience it's
like yes what the song is was in
addition to what I was feeling but it's
really that met that magic of the room
of this is our shot to make this happen
and the fact that this got agreement you
could see why especially in just a whole
room that was beautiful that was
absolutely beautiful
thank you so much for you for
recommending this one for her to be it
like the the front of that for it to be
her song to I how cool amazing that must
feel for her that's the soul of the
movie right there
well done man that
that I cried that was beautiful I had me
tearing up I was like moved to joy for
that really simple version for this song
to be the theme it's the best best
version best song out of all I'll give
you the actual theme
all right well spree thank you so much
that really helped set me free it
brought me a lot of Glee and you make
this boy really happy his name is
Gregory my lovely spree
what kind of spree like a shopping spree
or a crime she she has hot serial killer
written all over her face I want to go
on a spring spree where I just go on
like a different spree every day guys
you can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell and make
sure to check out our patreon page
because it's a Josh